pour le moment c'est le grand débrief et
oui hier soir m6 diffusait la 14ème
session de pékin express c'est une
saison particulière puisque le tournage
a été très perturbé à deux reprises la
première en raison de la crise sanitaire
bien entendu il linéraire a dû être
modifié et la seconde à cause d'un
accident de la route qui a impliqué des
candidats et l'équipe technique faute
c'est au côté audiences c'est le
meilleur lancement depuis 2014
mais c'est pas non plus n'est
normalement c'est pas fou c'est pas mal
2,9 millions téléspectateurs 13,6 et
c'est vrai que hier c'était les paysans
et ça m'a fait plaisir de les voir en
tête il y 5 millions de téléspectateurs
mais vous savez j'ai quand même un petit
faible pour stéphane rotenberg donc
j'aime bien quand ça marche pour lui
donc j'étais quand même content
descordes m6 hier soir même si m6 et la
production de pékin express a interdit à
l'oic qui va être avec nous dans un
instant de venir sur le plateau loïc je
vous dis on va voir les extraits les
plus drôles d'abord et vous allez voir
qu'on a eu tous les ingrédients qu'on
retrouve dans chaque saison de
l'émission va commencer par ceux qui ont
fait le plus réagir
c'est le premier duo loïc et sabine le
duo d'inconnus qui fait réagir
deux personnes qui ne se connaissent pas
et qui font l'aventuré ensemble on
regarde on est ensemble
ah ouais c'est moi
et pour être ma mère donc ça va être
très compliqué je fais ma musique
j'écoute pas du tout dérape jamais je
suis incapable de rater aujourd'hui
sabine et loïc ne sont pas du tout
d'accord sur la direction empruntée pour
avance on peut pas discuter du tout
avant que loïc il ne m'écoute pas dès
qu'on n'est pas d'accord il hausse le
ton tu m'écoutes parce que je te dis au
près contre est donc là tu commences
offerte à tête nanan assi jetez pas le
t'écoute découpage des balkans qu'il put
un vieux courrier mais tu veux pas là
comparable accélère alors commence pas à
me saouler je te parle pas depuis hier
je te parle pas je te calcule back
office alors encore sur les séquences
d'abord c'est pas très bien alors loïc
nous a rejoint merci le web est là
bonsoir bon je vous le dis j'ai un gros
coup de coeur pour loïc ouais il le sait
je le kiffe de ouf
donc je suis très content qu'il soit là
aujourd'hui hier donc tu as découvert
sabine petit problème tout vous opposer
les deux malheureusement voilà donc
c'est vrai que votre relation s'est
dégradée au fil de l'épisode
exactement c'est ce qui a été diffusé
chanter l'épisode le premier hier alors
c'est vrai que dans le montage
il ya des gens qui ont dit oui sur les
réseaux sociaux whale est pas cool tout
ça est ce que vous comprenez ça m'a un
petit peu puisque même moi je me suis
dit je suis pas cool non c'est vrai mais
pourquoi c'est le montage qui était à
charles gimat j'ai pas j'ai passé un
casting et un casting à tout un process
donc forcément on est pas on vient pas
nous chercher chez nous comme ça donc je
pense que s'ils se sont arrêtés sur mon
profil c'est qu'ils sont en scène
vincent cassel nous avons envoyé une
vidéo
voilà j'ai envoyé une vidéo j'en aurais
la deuxième après il ya plusieurs étapes
de cassinga passé et rencontrer des gens
contre le rédacteur la rédactrice en
chef parle même pas le producteur ouais
enfin ils vous ont dit beaucoup
et à la fin voilà bon coach si vous
étiez comme un fou de faire l'aventuré
j'étais je ne sais même pas comment fou
parce que cette aventure j'ai fait pour
eux j'ai une petite histoire des villes
un peu compliqué parce que j'ai failli
perdre ma fille au moment où j'ai passé
le casting d'accord que c'est un peu du
fichier laquelle ashfield là aujourd'hui
à 4,11 reza b maintenant je merci sony
c'est l'essentiel
merci voilà pékin express c'est sympa
mon sens balayette non mais c'est vrai
voilà c'est vraiment pour paris
il faut combat moi je voulais faire un
la représenter un petit peu à ma manière
alors dès le début ça a été très
compliqué entre vous et sabine dès la
première épreuve ne fallait pas gagner
sur des troncs d'arbres sur le lac
victoria une dispute a éclaté entre vous
et sabine regardes tu regarde même pas
qu'on tourne je vois pas contents de
concentrer tant sur nos régions
sabine ces joueurs là que je fais comme
si tu peux pas gagner tout seul alors qu
ils n'ont même pas ce que je te dis on
est bien
mais pas bien du tout j'en ai marre
d'avancé comme ça c'est tout les noms
des familles sabine
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup trop comme pour moi alors
loïc c'est vrai mon lolo et à sabine qui
revenue sur les détails voilà des
détails de votre aventure
elle a dit j'ai essayé d'être cool j'ai
essayé d'aller dans son sens il m'a
gâché mon aventure ce qui est dommage
c'est que je vivais des moments super
chouette dont on ne partage rien je me
disais la vente la nuit' nature et
luxuriante il me répondait des profs
d'histoire-géo toi ou pas je ne pouvais
rien partager ouais c'est un peu dur je
comprends que ça a choqué beaucoup de
téléspectateurs hier parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent oui c'est
vrai il a l'air hyper sympa ce soir et
c'est parce que on est pris dans une
compétition je suis parti pour faire une
course
ouais donc tient fondera c'est la crise
c'est à dire mais je le regrette a été
dur avec sami bien sûr vous lui avez
vous l'avez c'est d'abord on a parlé
quand même sur le chemin du retour pour
elle à l'aéroport pour prendre l'avion
on a mangé au restaurant avec l'équipe
qui nous encadrent et pour le
raccompagner
donc pour moi quand on n'a quand on est
reparti enfin voilà même si je me suis
déjà excusé c'est xavier mieux penser
que salim
voilà exactement après voilà bon sabine
elle est aussi une étude être éliminé la
poule a été frustré parce que recevoir
mon comportement
voilà se dit un grand guerre de deux
mètres en face b avec elle un peu
surprise mais avoir alors juste loïc moi
j'ai une question à vous poser
paraît que vous êtes très déçu aussi du
montage de l'émission il paraît que j'ai
raison ils ont pris que les moments où
vous étiez voilà deux voilà dans l'eure
dans la mauvaise humeur voilà alors que
vous étiez plutôt sympathique aux lois
du jeu à sanguin voilà donc surtout dans
la compétition je pense que n'importe
qui qui ont encadré
surtout que c'est lui
surtout que un bras enfin jeu ouais mais
qu'elle dit dans mon prix là je t'ai
pris dans lhassa a été axée sur mon
portefeuille je déteste perdre mais
vraiment ouais ouais ça moi je pourrais
pas jouer au tennis avec vous je vous
dis oui on est dans la voiture après moi
ce que j'aime loïc c'est qui dit quand
même qui regrette par rapport à sabine
et ça les gens qui font des erreurs on a
tous et des robes et j'aime bien que 18
lui donc voilà il était sportif jonathan
c'est un comportement parfois se
poursuivent eux au moins du tournoi
cependant vouloir était en voulait à la
production un peu est ce que c'est
vraiment pas du tout franchement je vais
je vais je vais pas cracher dans la
soupe mais assurément données montraient
bien c'est bien exploiter un énorme mais
j'étais quand même déçu et je me suis
pas mis leur faire savoir parce que il
ya un lien de cause à effet et on
s'énerve pas comme ça dans une invention
surtout comme quoi tous conservés alors
comme ça moi je m'énerve parce que
forcément je suis un compétiteur je
n'aime pas perdre
mais pourquoi est il forcément quand on
a des échanges où j'essaye d'imposer mes
idées et la production ça s'est mal
passé avec 1
franchement non sur le tournage tout
s'est bien passé c'est juste
l'encadrement après c'est sûr que tout
ce qui est contrôlée ça va être toute la
médiatisation les interviews qui vont
être qu'ils voulaient 5 juillet voilà il
ya des retours par rapport à ça
exactement où j'en étais pas tu vas pas
changer voilà tout est contrôlé à partir
du moment où on est obligé de passer par
une un service de communication c'est
obligé on y construit en es tu vas
passer avec moi j'ai eu des retours où
on va pas chercher mes temps dit on va
pas qui a tiré pourquoi je suis attendu
on va passer les méchants ils sont d'ici
là les méchants ils ont dit syrie
jamais jamais non je pense pas que voilà
moi je n'en mets qui cadix et la
production
moi j'ai le producteur en ligne ce matin
j'ai eu au téléphone ce matin
la rédactrice en chef j'aurai fait mon
retour alors bien sûr tu les écoutes
vachement les images qui sont parce que
voilà je suis pas comme je le dis je
suis un caractère sur les missions des
mois ce qui a été dégagé non ils ont
édulcoré à mort ou essayer d'estomper
comme ils pouvaient parce que j'ai été
pris dans l'aventuré tout semblait alors
on va revoir c'est vrai il ya eu votre
élimination hier vous étiez déçu quand
même d'être éliminés mais bien sûr gpj
comme je vous ai dit j'ai fait ça
pendant deux jours pour ma fille alors
est ce que vous êtes payé j'ai pas
d'accord bon bah ça veut dire oui gilles
verdez moi je comprends tout à fait ce
que ressent loric parce qu'en regardant
les images hier
moi même j'étais mal à l'aise c'est à
dire que j'ai trouvé que le casting est
particulièrement votre binôme tomber
dans la caricature et même dans le petit
portrait convoi de vous vous êtes
compétiteurs vous voulez gagner mais
vous n'êtes pas ce qu'on voit dans
l'émission là vous êtes avec l méchant
agressif et ça sonnait faux et je trouve
qu'ils ont fait un montage ils ont
orienté les missions en mer des
stéréotypes et des caricatures ça m'a
beaucoup gêné hier mois mais ce n'est
pas ce qu'ils racontent des histoires
huit options dont il doit montrer le
décalage entre loïc guillon expliquer un
peu les coulisses de ce genre d'émission
la balle à la maison adducteurs qui
parle c'est vrai ils ont une journée
pour sortir cinq dix quinze minutes des
missions utiles laurentiis et qui se
passe rien sur le tournage parce que
c'est bien beau la course mais si y'a
pas de l'histoire si y'a pas dû mais
entre les candidats un clac dès qu'ils
voient une aspérité il tire le fil
ils vont faire en sorte qu'ils se
classent tout le temps et c'est normal
qu'ils semblent un peu les ports ont
fait ensemble et je vais faire l'avocat
du diable 30 secondes mais je pense que
il c'est dur de condenser deux heures
d'émission
après voilà malheureusement comme j'ai
encore une fois j'ai été pris dans la
voix abidjan payet - il ya eu des bons
moments il ya qu à mort dont il tirait
rugby c'est un moment où je danse avec
les enfants qui a pas été montré à la
voile au monde comme un pacha elle qui
fait la lessive limitée gens elle a tout
fait j'ai rien fait mais c'est alors
vous savez quoi vous dire que ce qui
s'est passé mois loïc c'est que la
production au monde
ils ont des angles loïc et sabine volume
sort ils ont dû dire au monde leur
quitter l'émission tu me sors tous les
moments où ce clash et on va aller que
là dessus sur sur le couple logeait de
la chanson que
d'avoir quelqu'un comme taran trois
teams suis parce que voilà je sais mon
chum producteurs l'accord l'est pas ce
que je fais avec lui ces indépendants
voulais faire vous voulez un label moi
je fais de la musique d'accord j'ai pas
pour vivre de ma musique
vous êtes sportif un peu sa corne bref
c'était votre kit exactement telle
opportunité pour prouver ma fille mes
filles parce que j'en ai deux mais pour
prouver à mes filles que voilà parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent
aussi les gens font pékin express quand
ils sont pas pris dans koh lanta non
vous avez essayé koh lanta ou pas je
vais pas vous mentir nos maux ces
questions ou de pékin express parce que
comment quand j'aurai pas tout et je
pense que physiquement ce soit oui ben
haim non mais juste moi je voudrais
mettre un petit bémol quand même ce que
c'est toujours bien beau à chaque fois y
compris à koh lanta
les candidats quand ils reviennent et
qui sont pas contents des portraits ou 2
ou de l'image qu'ils ont donnée parce
qu'il était sous pression 10 oui mais
c'est pas moi puisque là vous avez vu
une image erronée de moi c'est la prod
c'est la faute à la presse
vous avez vu l'arrivée de l'eau n'est
pas vrai dire effectivement vous aviez
été un formidable et après on a dit qu
il avait anglais ils ont anglais
pourquoi parce que si 80 % du temps vous
étiez désagréable ils ont pris les 80%
du temps si ça avait été l'inversé 80 %
du temps sabine désagréable il aurait
fait sabine 80% du temps désagréable
il me semble mais avec vous voilà nous
enterrons parce que pour la simple et
bonne raison que sur un montage
encore une fois je le redis à deux
heures d'émission a condensé et qui est
très difficile mais quand on met en
avant un personnage qui fait que
s'énerve et on ne va pas faire pékin
express pour s'énerver
on s'énerve pas bêtement même si je suis
compétiteur je veux gagner je me bats
pour mes filles je viens pas engueulé
une femme de 50 ans comme c'est un gros
gain en ouganda avait pas faire 15
heures d'avion pour me fatiguer à
prendre la tête avec le fameux
maintenant j'ai été pris dans la
compétition parce que je n'aime pas
perdre et je le dis à paris qui fait un
jeu pour gagner pour pas pourquoi le
gagner pas moi ah bon enfin je joue à
puissance 4 me s'embrouille avec quatre
gars compenser téléspectateurs oui à 36%
non à 64% voilà comprenez vous la colère
de huit mois se trouve kolonick en tout
cas tu as été très franc et a dit les
choses et ça c'est le plus important et
je pense que les gens qui ont des
couvert ce soit comme tué à
l'entraînement on peut refaire cette
opportunité je suis très content voilà
et je t'explique si tu veux venir nous
voir qu'ils n'hésitent pas tu reviendras
tu veux mon chéri mais voilà ce qui va
perdre son cachet parce qu'il est venu
faire les missions assez bonne question
bernard montiel tiens je ne sais pas ce
que j'aime bien alors bravo bravo bravo
bravo pas mal de weegee souvent il ya
des clauses les candidats signent des
clauses et si balance un peu trop sur
les méchants ils ne touchent pas cette
somme d'argent qui est bloquée
normalement ces petits avec vous c'est
vrai et maire dévoile alors est-ce que
ce soir alors franchement bonjour
deschamps la structure c'est vraiment
c'est malheureux que se soit passé comme
ça parce qu'à l'image aurait vraiment
voulu qu'on voit et que l'on s'entende
bien que sabine maintenant ça sympa
match et c'est comme ça merci merci en
tout cas tu reviens de voir quand tu
veux je te lis mon look